When we read the
Quran, the Quran tells us that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala, he is our creator.
He's our sustainer. He is our
cherisher. Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
How many times have we thanked
Allah for the clothes he has given us?
Everything is because of Allah. The
clothes he has given us, the food that
we eat. How many times have we thanked
him for that? The house that he's given,
how many thanks have we thanked him for
that? All the wealthy he has given
us. The water we
drink, the water we drink, how many time
we thank Allah for the water we
drink, the air we breathe, if we do not
get the air for half an hour, one hour,
you will die.
How many of us have thanked Allah for
the air? The air that we breathe because
of which we
survive. I want to know in this
auditorium. Can you raise your hand? How
many of us have thanked Allah for the
air? Only for the air. Please raise your
hand. 1 2 3
Okay, maybe 5%. Okay, 5% have
thanked
Allah. Imagine if we don't get the
air. Some may after few minutes, some
after 10 minutes, some after half an
hour. No one can hold the breath. No one
can hold the breath for more than 1
hour. The world record is not 1
hour. So imagine if we don't get the
air, we will die.
That reminds me of a saying and we keep
on cribbing. We don't have this, we
don't have that, we don't have this, we
don't have
that. You know, there was a man who used
to complain because he has no shoes. He
used to complain to God because he has
no shoes until he saw a man who had no
feet. A person used to complain to God
because he had no shoes until he saw a
man who had no feet.
Therefore, the Islamic concept
is in terms of wealth, look at the
people below you and thank Allah, I'm
better than him. As far as wealth is
concerned, the worldly things are
concerned, the Islamic Sharia says look
at the people below you and thank Allah.
And when knowledge is concerned, dean is
concerned, virtue is concerned, look at
the people above you and try and lead
that level. But as far as the wealth and
the dunya is concerned, look at the
people below
you. And Allah says in surah fat chapter
number 35 verse number
that Allah is free of all wants, worthy
of all praise.
Allah says in
surah chapter number 100 verse number
six that man is verily
ungrateful. Allah is giving us all this
nyama and we are
ungrateful. Even though you're
ungrateful you ask for forgiveness,
Allah forgives you. Allah is raman or
rahim. However mistakes we do, however
ungrateful you are, whatever sins we do,
when we ask for forgiveness, Allah
forgives you.
Allah
says
that for verily Allah is most forgiving.
In surah Nisa chapter 4 verse number 25,
in surah Maida chapter number 5 verse
number 74, in surah hijar chapter number
15 verse number 49, in surah nah chapter
number 16 verse number 119 and in surah
bur chapter number 85 verse number
14 that verily Allah is most
forgiving and
merciful. And Allah says in surah nisa
chapter number four verse number
48 and in surah nisa chapter 4 verse
number
that if Allah
pleases he may forgive any
sin
but anyone who joins partners with
gods he has done the most hinous sin he
has gone far way. That means Allah is
saying in chapter 4:48 and in chapter
416, you do anything sin and Allah if he
pleases will forgive you but the sin of
shik he'll never forgive. So if you die
as a mushik if you die doing shik Allah
will never forgive
you if you do shik and you ask for
forgiveness before dying Allah will
forgive that also but if you die as a
mushik without asking for forgiveness
that sin Allah will never forgive. So
shik is the biggest sin in
Islam. It is the most hinous sin in
Islam.